Salam alaikum we're here in put the
child that's about seven kilometers
roughly from Stella Bonita this is where
the greatest genocide Havana's popular
he left Paris to dissipate his readiness
for subscribing in a pond or it's not
that the same person who never killed
out here
thought she was letting me know
impossible turn it was the greatest
genocide happened after World War two
we're gonna look at the memorial that's
been set up look at some history and
bring to light some of what's been
forgotten so be with us let's go ahead
and continue our journey here in Bosnia
all these are the names of the yes those
all the names all the names of people
who died here yes yes how many total
cuckoo cuckoo
Christian is do you probably be cattle
nutria [ __ ] smoke travel equivalent
Sentra not you complex nitrogenous
Vienna Roger wicker he told Fatima
but mrs. Nana star stars to me sadhana
cut the puddle called a Picasso podoleni
agura Porsche mama
now do the seven CBO the Buddha below
even a notch to stability energy
Villanova Barbara Lobos the sasada each
ethnicity or vices kowalska Dino fatty
because row seat to also another that
she who is a street magician
obviously proposed to treat asthma dolly
soon as any regina email yet they do sub
to Ozma prima quad no more car trouble
casting severely only Queenie steel
Adagio the supercommittee shall cast
Robert Horry Tom Oh criminy sacatepéquez
to Stoughton you kill me topic Osama no
cop inertia slit research addressed
ba-da-bop Oguma boards are notches
relied etc - Cooper Austin he retrieves
some decid Volvo D Sekou Ludacris
boggling always very Madonna struggle
accepting the Adonis who like not score
at Villa the rodeos Nina
Paul Masson raghunatha inaudible mr.
Perot massively grenades also be a
Ludhiana see Bosley Kapil Roop tera
Mastana Cropsey to Suey
yonder captain a quatrain the more
people Batsy value notches prema no
second our Taku dasa desa Diana trek
anonymous Panaji ruku Nadu gonna you
know go nach - the South shadows that
y'know Trek a competitive not enough
room it's nationally ruku neg denote
will make the locker otaku gua we talk
in Memorial Center exactly put a chair
is the name of this area this is between
strabonitz and retinas this was place
was basically the United Nations safe
zone until it became not so safe for
these victims give them Johnny these
people basically well this is not people
from Stribling so which was which is
misconception with most people this is
area which was safe zone and all the
Muslims from all the places around were
running here because the Serbian
aggressors were coming and burning their
villages killing everybody so they were
all running away
and this was United Nations safe zones
supposed to be safe but then we know
unfortunate events that happened and
evolved later that most of these people
who became who came here were separated
man from women and then women who had
their own destiny after and men most of
the meals were killed here some of them
we see the graves there some of them
they are staying approximately around
2000 where we don't know how many still
missing so and this is now we're about
to enter the museum we're looking at
some of the footages from those horrible
days and we have some
since here it says that like the goal of
these mothers who were separated which
we see in the picture here says to
protect the young offspring and to find
out the first news about the male males
from from their families females and
kids and very old people who were let go
to the safe to the territory which was
under control of this is a former
battery factory it used to be before the
war during the war it was base of United
Nations forces touch peacekeepers they
were located here this building building
where we are now
Dutch soldiers used as parking space for
their vehicles when turbulent FL under
control army of Republika Srpska 11th of
July in 1995 when refugees arrived here
in Porto Charlie - soldiers decided to
move out vehicles and here in this big
hole located five to six thousand
refugees who spent 2 days and 2 nights
when Bosnian Serb forces deported women
and children who stayed outside when
they separate men and boys then Dutch
soldiers told this group that they had
to go on checkpoint and on that
checkpoint Bosnian Serb forces separate
men and boys who were here in the base
same light people who stayed outside and
that is reason why today we use this
hole as as memorial room there in the
cemetery you saw the number of victims
of genocide instruments are 8000 372
victims who are who were killed during
the genocide instruments are there in
the cemetery we have a memorial wall
with all the names of victims of
genocide reverence and until today here
in the cemetery
here in poor Charlie we have Barry just
6643 victims of genocide in reverence
more than one and half thousand people
are still missing wood they are not
buried here in the cemetery you know
every year on anniversary day here in
poor Charlie have new annual
commemoration a new burial day for new
identified victims of genocide reverence
and this year we very just 33 victims of
genocide
it's a feeling that I just can't you
just got to imagine you have civilians
innocent men women children who are
running for their lives who are thinking
they've come under UN protection so
imagine that the Dutch battalion were
there to protect the people who lived
there they didn't they should have done
you're coming into this factory here as
you can see they're coming into this
safe zone it's supposed to be a safe
zone Osborne yoga very edgy
nobuta say all same Salaam but up not
being so safe so United Nations you have
the the Dutch Holland troops they are
supposed to be protecting putting their
lives on the line it reminds me you know
if if it was the other way around you
know when someone is God conscious when
someone knows that there's a higher
being above them watching it reminds me
of the verse the ayah in the Quran where
the Almighty God Almighty is saying
saving one innocent life is as if you
saved all of mankind so imagine if those
people see when your godless when you
don't have the consciousness of your
creator imagine if they had this
consciousness and they knew and they
were aware of the immense reward of
saving an innocent life they would have
been able to put their lives on the line
to save to prevent the greatest genocide
after World War two but that's what
happens when you separate I
you throw out morality the ultimate
morality and God out of your life so
that's just what comes to my mind so you
have the safe zone and that I'm not
being so safe you have imagined this
area now all of these innocent human
beings coming running for their lives
and then what happens next they start
separating the men's that meant the
young boys and the men and then the
women we hear women are being raped when
you imagine that a horrific scene and we
often hear never forget so we're
bringing this to light for many who have
no idea what happened here so we can
truly never forget to prevent something
like this from ever happening again
again only please know that he killed
100 people and he got five years of
prison so we got a chance to see like
this abandoned Factory and just
envisioning the scene you get to see the
war criminals who were convicted and you
get to see people who were killing one
instance a man killed a hundred people
can you imagine and he got five years
yes
so then how we came to know most of
these facts is people were coming up
there conscious many were now just
coming up coming forward and they were
giving up the others and saying that
they were forced to do these things
because of their higher-ups
now we come over here and we see some of
the things some of the artifacts of what
some of the from Holland the soldiers
the UN peacekeepers who are supposed to
be protecting the innocent human beings
who sought refuge here you can see here
what they found in the rock walls one
right I'm your best friend
I kill you for nothing this is in 94
another one here it's interesting you
fight you have to cross here you have a
cross here and he says killing killing
is my business and business is good the
freemen but the demon operating the
hassanis require direct no which snakes
not she direct me muchas new
[Music]
ghannouchi do not chew toy daka's are no
new prezz measurement Sudama no cousin
the emmitt a video clip scorpio owning
the previs lollipop
ah si esta la madone Kidani do is a pro
strasser be approached reposted Tsugumi
unique was esteban neck of noon what its
own on my knee shadi
the only private you not see approached
erma Bosnia soon where he was me okay
Italy and she too soon to stay story
questions and Nando Cassie question
Ivanovich Dugas Rani name and in Dundalk
as the Bosnia heart so hardly the attack
was not doing our Agnetha that the
sabili organs the money that they two
organs on Diavolo that the Nicky Effendi
I'll make Imam Nostra political esto le
pas slow odd region group scoopin
renewed I became Muslim Aaron iturra
Danny Tony da cousin was actually
measuring pseudo proud this to do castle
that planet subscribers monitor clubs
interesting that these what they call
the extreme
Serbs or the techniques you never really
have their faith brought up into it but
we know that their guns were being
blessed by priests you never get
Christianity brought into it but they
were actually not only on the part of
the nationalism but also you see these
people who are doing a modern-day
crusade now again we don't blame
Christianity just the same way you
cannot go ahead and if some fringe
element do something and the person has
a name that's that's connected to Islam
has nothing to do with Islam so we don't
brain Christianity but it's just
interesting that you never see their
religion brought it into it but you can
equate this to a modern-day crusade that
was happening because these were
Christians and they were as you can see
both of them working together and they
let what's supposed to be a safe zone of
protection for them they let the
greatest genocide after World War Two
happen under their watch
[Music]
fascinating children would come anyway
Mooresville and yoga very edgy now Boyd
this Austin Salaam if this doesn't work
John what do you think it will do to the
people because it's mood work you have
here all the participants all the people
some of the people that were found
guilty and the the main ones here from
the president and the main generals now
these people were Christian that is
undisputable but we don't blame
Christianity I make this point because
they were leading a modern-day crusade
but you'd hardly ever if ever hear
anyone bring any normal person knows
that this has nothing to do with
Christianity the true teachings of
loving your neighbor I mean it just
reminds me of a passage from the Bible
in the Gospel of Matthew where one came
to Jesus said oh good master what good
thing what good thing can I do that I
may have inherit the kingdom meaning how
do I get the paradise he said why are
you calling me good
this is allegedly Jesus saying why why
do you call me good there's none good
but God Almighty so here we see he's
just differentiating himself from God
then he said what else he said then you
got to keep the commandments and then
after listening a bunch of them he said
love your neighbor so this is a great
example for others who are Serbian
Christian or whoever to remember this
and to remember those teachings those
true teachings that you have in your
Bible of loving your neighbor because if
you love your neighbor truly you will
not ever let something like this happen
again not even thinking about it let
alone coming close to it so these were
Christians
but we don't blame Christianity and it's
a great lesson because you have much of
the media that tries to use Muslims
escape ghosts Islam as a scapegoat so
anytime some lunatic does something they
try to put Islam on the witness stand
call Muslims terrorists and spread this
mass manipulation feeding the people
these lies half-truths and what this
does is creates fear in people and then
you attack what you fear and this is
what we saw happen more than 20,000
people stayed outside in front base
behind the blue building they were not
able to enter in the base there on the
main road there was a checkpoint for
Bosnians sir four separate men and boys
and first day they sent them to the
house across the road it's called White
House where they torture them and then
they deported them to the territory of
most parties Bonnie who are they
shooting all of them now once you
division it I mean the United Nations
are there too as peacekeepers and
they're supposed to protect these
innocent non-combatants civilians and
that's why they were running here who
actually had signs that we saw back over
there standing for United nothing yeah
because they did nothing this is the the
head telling everybody that the good
news you're all safe what a liar
okay so what is this now this is the
Dutch soldiers celebrating in zagreb
crash after they left from 7:00 it's
after sermons FL why are they
celebrating I mean this is the job was
done so while the Muslims are being
massacred these guys are celebrating and
there was just after they attend to this
kunis official delegation including the
Dutch crown prince the prime minister
members of the Parliament had travelled
to Zagreb the Dutch army
commander-in-chief insisted on having a
party the evenings offered the beer and
the music contribute to the feelings of
relief and joy among the soldiers who
had survived their mission however
survivors and many others saw it as a
totally inappropriate time for a party
commanders here all these people who
this is one of the beautiful things now
that our Deen teaches that they might be
able to get away with all of this evil
in this life but that's why there's a
day of judgment and the ultimate
reckoning will be there and these
criminals will be held to account on the
greatest court in front of the Creator
on the day of recommended a judgement
terrible
[Applause]
[Music]
we pray for all those innocent human
beings the victims and their families
who had to suffer this horrible tragic
ordeal this is the headquarters the
command center for the for the UN Dutch
who was supposed to be protecting these
civilians you're getting to see live
here some of the old equipment that they
were using this is the actual
headquarters post for this area here the
room that they were using can show you
many of the pictures on the wall just
provocative pictures of naked women many
disgusting things the soldiers were
writing on the walls now this is the
state of the human being when he doesn't
have took all God consciousness he will
brings the human down to the lower than
an animal you can come in these rooms
and you can go ahead and see some of the
videos that they prepared this is the
graveyard and memorial these are all
human beings
this is human life that has been taken
and there is a slogan here also that has
said never forget never forget seven
Itza unlike the slogan that we hear
often when we hear never forget we
usually attribute it to 911 and what we
say about that is anywhere where human
life is taken human life in a mirror
human life in Afghanistan in Bosnia
innocent human life taken is innocent
human life we condemn all acts of evil
of terrorism but here we know exactly
who those terrorists were who
perpetuated this great degrade is
genocide after world war 2 where you had
all these people here they were killed
unjustly so I often say never forget yes
never forget that Islam and Muslims had
nothing to do at all with 9/11 but here
instead of Annisa never forget that
these Crusaders who were actually
Christian and their theology and
ideology still stems is alive and you
had the New Zealand terrorists who
perpetuated that ideology and you have
many others these Islamophobes who are
out there trying to revive this who are
trying to who are actually going away
from the true teachings of Jesus because
we know this does not represent true
Christianity which is about loving your
neighbor so we need to work together as
human beings who are on this earth
together to make it a more peaceful and
livable place for all because there is
only one creator and he created us all
and he is the one who will judge between
us so it's not on us to take innocent
human life that is sacred according to
all religions especially the way of life
from the crater Islam where it says
killing in his one innocent human being
is as if you kill the world and if these
Dutch these people these UN forces would
have been implementing God's divine law
of saving one innocent life is as if you
saved the world they would have not have
let this genocide happen
we're here in stubborn inside